[Music]
two tribes have gone to war over brexit
but this draining national sorrow has
all but forgotten when two Footballers
Wives wags locked horns and the entire
nation got the popcorn in for those who
missed this epic clash a recap mrs.
Wayne Rooney devised a forensic
elaborate sting operation to find out
which follower on her private Instagram
account with selling stories to the
tabloids
Colleen blocked all her followers bar
one the leaks continued then wagga Ferg
Christie delivered the killer reveal its
dot dot dot dot Rebecca VAR DS account
missus Jamie Vardy has denied it all and
tearfully instructed her lawyers no
panel to the big question of our time
was this offside or back of the net
should Colleen have picked up the phone
rather than put missus body through
trial by Twitter or should we accept
that social media is where the bloodiest
battles are fought these days I think
it's only right we get our wagon all
right I'll tell you what I've got to say
a few years ago now someone who I
trusted to follow me on my personal
Instagram account has been consistently
informing the Sun newspaper of my
private posting stories now I know for
certain from which it count individual
it's come from I've saved the
screenshots all the original stories
which clearly show this one just one
person has viewed them it's Rebecca VAR
DS accounts what have you got to say for
yourself over the years various people
have had access to my insta and just
this week I found out I was following
people I did
no and it never followed myself I'm not
being funny but I don't need the money
and what would I gain from selling
stories on you clean I don't know you
tell me something from Rita cabins and
as a professor of politics because I
think it's a really interesting insight
she says when someone makes an off-color
remark in person few people respond by
gathering everybody to berate the
speaker publicly in an Orwellian two
minutes of hate and then throw that
person out the building which would be
the roughly the physical equivalent of
an Internet pile on social media
diminishes both the discomfort of seeing
our victim suffering and the shame of
being seen making them suffer encouraged
I think that's where this conversation
goes and you mentioned the whole social
in some aspects it's fantastic you you
keep friendships going with people the
other side of the world it's an
incredible tool for good you can get
research you can get the Gettysburg
Address as quick as I'm it's quite
extraordinary but on the other side and
I think we're all still learning in all
honesty about this on the other side it
can be a very dark force in all sorts of
areas slurs are made threats and made
language I wouldn't dream of saying to
you or to you in the street but I can do
it hiding behind some weird bizarre name
like cheeky coffee or something that's
that is in street protest when you put a
mask on like you see sometimes far right
and far as well put the mask on what
you're doing is you're basically saying
and now I'm no longer a human I'm an
entity involved in a purpose and you
allow yourself you permit yourself to do
things that you wouldn't do in your
human definition so on social media that
nonnamous identity is the equivalent of
the mark I knew IRA chap interviewed
yesterday on the news who wore a mask
for that reason if he wouldn't be you
know say what he was saying if people
could see who he was but on the question
of was this fair you know was Colleen
fair to do this to a friend or was she
using that as it were the surveillance
tool
of social media to achieve something
could have been because if there is then
she should have probably spoke to her
first
can we just hear from what the director
of the National Center for cyber
stalking says it is extremely pertinent
to this when it comes to social media I
think people are conducting a level of
surveillance on one another especially
on ex-partners which is unhealthy
after breakup it is almost impossible to
remove a person and their influence from
your online feeds we are now all public
figures we all have a social media
profile and we're all at risk from
individuals who may become fixated on
what we represent so even though Colleen
and Rebecca Vardy were nationally known
figures this could happen you know but
in a little village somebody could cyber
stalk someone else they call them out
and destroy their lives you said in your
intro that the entire nation is being
ripped I could not gossiping I found it
so embarrassing I find this airing of
dirty laundry on social media classless
inelegant and just pack it in if you've
got a problem with someone deal with it
which is why I've been trolling Rachel
Johnson's parody Twitter account tonight
and here just some of Rachel's suppose
inches why am i so violently against
brexit I'm doing it cause I want my kids
to have the same opportunities I have
had in the last three months I've been
to France Italy in Greece twice I was
also drawn to this one most people think
the pledge is what the daily use is for
polishing the sideboard wake up Gammons
it's the electrifyingly web TV show
featuring me
running rings around old duffer Nick
Ferrari imagine being called Ferrari and
looking like an unmade bed actually to
your central point it's it's great for
the newspapers it's great for the media
because you've got to be but four
powerful people in our society these
people just they've got by a friend
similar to this this day nobody knows
what I think nobody knows but obviously
those who were there and witnessed it
know about it but I don't announce it I
don't speak about it and now I'm not
mentioning the name of the friend
something is actually actually
unforgivable somebody sold a story about
you or similar patron of a friendship
but it wasn't involving selling a story
right and all I'm going to say is that
actually I just think you're right I
think there is some elegance and dignity
to not you know to shaming people in
public when they know they've done
something wrong so what the person knows
that doesn't think there is something
right just a quick one to say I mean
obviously we are berating social media
but there are lots of positive elements
in fact there's a Deloitte global
millennial survey and they found that 42
percent of Millennials feel that social
media enhances their self-worth so there
is the good side - like the drug lock
effects with every time get a like and
your brain tells you like what is it I
know so many YouTube videos when I'm
trying to learn something new and
actually there's inspirational
use words elegance and dignity social
media though I mean she should have I
think you know I basically what I did
after that betrays I called the person
right the person knows what they did has
not tried to defend it ever once and I
just think there's something more
dignified in them knowing that you know
that they know now the whole world knows
we're cleaning right we've all heard
about knocking on heaven's door but not
so much knocking on the lid of your own
coffin wiles funerals are usually a time
to reflect remember and celebrate the
life of a loved one it's not often the
deceased gets a speaking role but that's
exactly what happened at the burial of
cher Bradley in Ireland last week where
mourners were left in shock after
hearing his voice from beyond the grave
the 62 year old ensured that he got the
last laugh is urn send-off leaving his
family and friends in fits of giggles
rather than for showing us how to truly
common style cher has to you and your
famous last words may you rest in peace
the best way of all that by the way is
much it not having a
imagine right that's all we've got time
for this week on the pledge I'll explain
jokes to you later you guys can join in
our debate by searching for us on
Twitter and you can also listen to the
show on the go just subscribe using
Apple podcasts Spotify or whatever you
prefer thanks for watching I will see
you next time
[Music]